hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
Dr fauci is still around
why we have no idea it's called the
fauci effect which is sort of like you
know as
trust me I'm I I don't get excited about
that
I mean it's nice but I mean it's it's
I people go to medical school now people
are interested in science not because of
me because people most people don't know
me who I am my friends know me my wife
knows me but people don't know me it's
what I symbolize and what I symbolize in
a
in an era of the normalization of
untruths and lies and and all the things
you're seeing going on in society from
January 6th to everything else that goes
on people the craving for consistency
for integrity for truth and for people
caring about people when you tell people
they need to mask in an indoor
congregate setting when you're in a a
Zone
that has a high Dynamic of infection and
that is looked upon by a lot of people
not everybody as as an encroachment on
your freedom
um that we've never had that before I
mean so I mean it it's it's almost
inexplicable right we're at the
epicenter of the initial outbreak
wa1 Washington one is considered the
ancestral model strain
um this Center I developed the answer
I created it that's right you Let it
Loose loose I was in my kitchen yeah
right okay data function here we come
you were here making aracha in the
Italian meatballs and that's a gain of
function
all right